[Musique]
est ce que tu trouves que les jolis noms
oui pour moi oui oui c'est la plus jolie
femme qui connaît donc bien c'est
pourquoi je ne sais pas parce que ces
mamans les jeux l'état mais contre moi
comment elle et je l'avais chemine du
jeu châtain l'adhésion marron vert
comment sa voix douce
grandes ou petites grandes mais surtout
quand elle mais c'est au talent parce
que ça la grande île beaucoup non
tu aimes quand elle met ses hauts talons
ben non pour beaucoup parce que je vois
pas comment venir parce que c'est ça
fait un peu snob sks qu'à une tenue
qu'elle porte que tu préfères à d'autres
ainsi quand elle intègre à son travail
pourquoi parce que j'aime bien son
manteau avec le col de fourrure un bon
manteau bleu clair avec un col de
fourrure mais c'est joli ce oui il est
bon alors ça ça va mieux les bosses avec
un retour de froid lotois et en quoi
elle pourrait être remplacée gentillesse
une affection
une personne peut en avoir là une
affection mais pas la même percée sait
pas on a besoin ap aussi mais le
principal mandat besoins de sa mère mais
tu tues tu vas me dire pourquoi la mère
est toujours un petit peu plus
indulgente deux paires et impaires ça ça
fait pas tout ce qu'une mère
faire ça tricote pas les plus longues
par exemple ça fait pas la crise il y
aura quelques fois on m'a présenté à
l'accasion le fait bien et que j'y étais
mais très très bien très bien
elle devait les placer au mieux à oui
quoi parlent ils sont durs il veut du
jouet les locaux tiennent bien ça aussi
un jour ta maman partez où enfin elle
n'était plus la maison qu'elle
disparaisse de ta vie est-ce que s
caisse elle te manquera beaucoup
oui on est en émoi pourquoi parce que
[Musique]
parce qu'ils ont tout à 10h ne se dit
pas si pour le moment je pleurais
je mangerai pas pourquoi
un jeune aurait pu pays je pourrais
perdre la marine non pourquoi ce
irremplaçable
c'est parce qu'elle fait à manger c'est
parce que j'ai trop coupé toute façon et
qui sera jamais la maison je peux pas
savoir
[Musique]